they're hunting for bullet holes an
agonizing search for punctured skin
the doctors count four but there may be
more
Adam is another victim of Arab militia
attacks in Darfur he couldn't walk so
his friend carried him to safety on his
back across the border and brought him
here
[Music]
they came on horses camels and cars
Muhammad says
and as he waits by his friend the tent
fills with the wounded but these are the
survivors
they're cleaning blood from the floor
it belongs to Fatma
shot in their head as she fled the
violence in elginena
he said that she was seven months
pregnant based on the ultrasound but
she's got more of her children outside
her children lay on her sister zainab's
lap only five and seven years old
[Music]
says her young nephew was holding his
mother's body when the cart arrived at
their Village in chat
how is your heart I ask
she says my heart isn't here I don't
know how to feel
[Music]
she's building calls from relatives
across the region phoning to pay their
condolences
but one call doesn't come
Adam fatma's husband is trapped in the
violence of elginana with no signal
he's yet to find out that his wife and
unborn child are being prepared for
burial
she's carried out to her final
destination in her chosen place of
refuge and under the pain of her family
is a sense of fearful dread that more
grief is on the way
Sky News Eastern chat